foreign
[Applause]
thanks so much everyone before I begin I
do want to give just a small content
warning I am going to be discussing
discussing contemporary forms of slavery
they are fairly severe human rights
abuses I'm not going to go into the
specific details of any individual
survivor's story but I will be providing
illustrative examples of the kinds of
practices that are included within the
umbrella of modern slavery it is a
serious topic and it and sometimes it
can hit you even if you know it's coming
when we think about the concept of
slavery a fairly clear picture emerges
the slavery you've seen on TV and in the
movies the slavery you might have read
about in history books the slavery
commemorated in museums the slavery you
may have been taught about in schools
it's a very specific phenomenon
maybe it's hands bound and shackles
maybe it's bodies packed together on the
floor of a ship's hold maybe it's
toiling on a field with the crack of a
whip whistling overhead
the Specter of transatlantic enslavement
looms large and understandably so 12.5
million people forcibly displaced from
their homes to be shipped across the
ocean on a brutal voyage that would
claim the lives of two million human
beings before they even made it to
foreign Shores
and the legacies of that system are
alive today
enslavers and the people they enslaved
built the modern Western world
and the broken promise of emancipation
and Reformation continues to shape all
of our lives
but it's also important to understand
that this image of slavery is specific
and contextualized in a time and in a
place
and yet it's not the only time in human
history that a group of people decide
that they could treat another as if they
were less than human and exploited them
as if they were property
slavery infuses our human history as far
back as written records extend human
beings have enslaved one another
from ancient Greece Rome and the near
East to the sasanian abyssidian and
Acadian Empires from the first Global
economies in the Indian Ocean and Asian
worlds to early Islamic law Hindu
rajya's medieval Korea and early
Christianity systems of enslavement are
well documented
with such a long and storied history
it's really no surprise that slavery
continues to be found in our world today
and it has many faces
there is no single image of enslavement
in our contemporary world
in abstract terms modern slavery is a
term used to describe a set of practices
Each of which is connected to the core
of slavery and international law and
Each of which involves severe human
exploitation
and dehumanization
we have slavery itself not only chattel
slavery that defines a human being as
property in law but also de facto
slavery where the same relationship and
behaviors manifests without the
protections of law
and then we also have forced labor that
is work or service exacted under minutes
of penalty for which a person has not
offered themselves voluntarily we have
servitude which is an exacerbated form
of of forced labor somewhere between
forced labor and slavery debt bondage
where a person is bound to work to repay
a debt but the conditions of the debt
are such that it can never be repaid and
they are forced to work in perpetuity
and they cannot leave
we have false marriages where people are
forced or coerced into a marriage
against their will and often forced to
labor and sexually exploited in that
context and finally human trafficking
where people are recruited transported
transferred harbored or received through
coercive means for the purpose of
exploitation
in more concrete terms
modern slavery as a young man in Brazil
promised a decent job to help feed his
family trafficked onto an agricultural
Plantation fenced and locked in held at
gunpoint forced into hard labor 17 18 20
hours a day and fed with the pigs
it's a child in the Philippines being
abused by a family member live streamed
for the sexual gratification of
pedophiles in North America Europe and
Australia it's a woman in Bangladesh
working grindingly long hours for very
little pay in unsafe conditions
so that multinational companies can
churn out ever cheaper garments for the
fast fashion Mill
it's a man in Libya being sold on an
auction block
it's a yazidi woman forced into a
marriage with a man that killed everyone
she knew
it's a child being forced into a battle
and it's not something that's only
happening far away from you
it's a 13 year old boy in Manchester
forced by criminal organizations to
traffic drugs across county lines with
no way to escape and no choice under
threat and coercion
as a young woman in Birmingham whose
family are forcing into her her into a
marriage with a man 20 years older than
her
that she doesn't know and forced into a
life of domestic servitude and coerced
sex
it's a migrant worker who came to the UK
on a promise of a decent legal job
forced under threat of violence to him
and his family to cultivate cannabis
working for no pay held in inhuman
conditions and told if he goes to the
police they will send him to prison
it's a hundred and twenty two thousand
lives in this country and 50 million
people around the world human beings
exploited as if they were property and
treated as if they were disposable
slavery touches all of our lives in many
different ways it's in our towns and in
our cities it's in our factories and on
our Farms
and every 550 people in this country
there is a person in modern slavery
it's also
that we estimate
that we think we know about
it's also in many of the things we buy
use wear and eat
the UK Imports about 21 billion US
Dollars no pounds 21 billion pounds
worth of goods at high risk of having
been produced using forced labor in only
their top five high-risk Imports that's
garments Electronics fish textiles and
Timber
there are many more products and
commodities that we import as well as
services that we offshore that are also
at risk
and this is a tricky one because the
growth in consumer culture demand for
goods and increasing globalization of
our trade and Supply chains have both
positive and negative impacts
on the one hand it can help to fuel
development and Innovation bring
critical new income streams to people in
developing country and ultimately
increase quality of life
but on the other hand it can lead to
exploitation and abuse as well as
environmental degradation
how does this work
let's think about just one high-risk
product
the clothing that all of us are wearing
because this is not a nudist Festival
there are risks of modern slavery at
every stage in the Garment supply chain
from growing and producing raw materials
to processing these into textiles to
Manufacturing
and we can start at the very far end of
the supply chain
with raw materials
let's look at the shirt you're wearing
the shirt you're wearing
things that most people in this room are
wearing which involve cotton cotton
production in many countries is heavily
implicated in both boss labor and child
labor
China is now the single largest producer
of cotton in the global economy 5.9
million metric tons in the 2021-22 crop
year
about 90 of China's cotton is now
produced in the xinjiang wiga autonomous
region where the Chinese government has
instituted a system of repression
including crimes against humanity and
human rights abuses against the uygha
Kazakh and other predominantly Muslim
Muslim ethnic minority populations
the government has detained millions of
uyghurs and subjected them to forced
labor predominantly in the production of
tomatoes polysilicon and cotton
and it's not just a China problem forced
labor and cotton production has also
been found in Benin Burkina Faso
Kazakhstan Pakistan Tajikistan
Turkmenistan and Uzbekistan some of the
largest cotton producers in the world
cotton then needs to be processed raw
cotton is ginned spun and woven into the
textiles that make up our clothes
and here cotton from multiple sources is
combined into a single fabric making it
very difficult to ensure that cotton
from a particular high-risk context has
not made its way into the cotton being
produced for your garments
and then there's an additional risk of
exploitation in this stage
a lot of the textile production is also
done in xinjiang under the same system
of forced labor under which the cotton
is produced and in many other Asian and
Pacific countries
textile production is subcontracted to
home-based workers without formal
contracts which makes them vulnerable
and one more step removed from oversight
in the supply chain
with tight turnaround times and Tiny
profit margins the risk of exploitative
working conditions is high
in India a practice known as sumangali
is employed where women and girls are
offered employment in spinning Mills
with payment in a lump sum at the very
end of their contract
they're then subjected to restrictions
on their movement forced to work long
hours exposed to physical and sexual
abuse and unable to leave before their
contract ends without risking losing
their entire earnings
textiles are then manufactured into
garments this can also take place
through these informal subcontracted
home-based work without formal contracts
making people at risk of exploitation
and garment factories in many different
countries subject workers predominantly
women and girls to exploitative working
conditions and unsafe environments
workers in Ethiopia were found to be
earning as little as 12 cents an hour in
addition to then experiencing wage
deductions as punishment verbal abuse
and forced over time
and although we started at the very far
end of the supply chain the pressures
that drive these exploitative conditions
come from much closer to home
the brands trying to cater to rapidly
changing consumer preferences make
unrealistic and inappropriate demands of
suppliers pressuring them to deliver
faster and at lower cost this pressures
the suppliers to reduce their labor
costs and increase working hours
exacerbating the risk of Labor abuse
and during the covid-19 pandemic we saw
extreme examples of Brands canceling
orders for products that had already
been manufactured and refusing to pay so
the workers were dismissed denied
payment for the work that they had
already completed for a western brand
and ultimately wages were driven even
further down and working conditions
worsened
there are a lot of power imbalances in
asymmetrical relationships in Global
Supply chains these imbalances
perpetuate A system that allows
significant profits to be generated
mostly at the top while the same
entities that hoard this profit drive a
race to the bottom at every subsequent
step in the supply chain
Primark reported an operating profit of
756 million pounds in 2022.
Sheen the new online fashion giant
reported profit of about 700 million US
dollars in 2022 and 1.1 billion dollars
in 2021.
if just a fraction of that profit was
shared across the supply chain instead
of hoarded by investors it could make a
substantial difference in the lives of
people working at every stage of
production
and I should say it's not just low-cost
brands that are implicated in this Prada
scored only five out of ten five out of
a hundred on know the chains fashion and
apparel Benchmark and yet they
registered a profit of 465 million euros
in 2022.
we talked about the exploitation that
went into making your pockets
now let's talk about the exploitation
that goes into the thing that lives in
your pocket your phone
phones are a much more complicated
supply chain
because of the constituent parts that go
into it there are very many and they're
very complicated so I'm just going to
talk about one
and everyone's phone in this room
there is a lithium ion rechargeable
battery
they're also inside our tablets laptops
electric cars
and inside every single lithium-ion
battery on the planet is a substance
called Cobalt
the majority of the world's Cobalt is
mined in the Democratic Republic of the
Congo a vast country in the middle of
Africa 11 times the size of Great
Britain
and we're not talking about a little bit
more Cobalt than anywhere else we're
talking about 70 percent of the entire
world's Cobalt production in 2022. and
this isn't likely to change anytime soon
because it's estimated that 50 of the
entire world's Cobalt Reserve resides in
this one country
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas